[Music]
yo supplies won't understand me will
Leeds welcome to this week's winners on
a Wednesday I'm a property investor but
one of the things I love doing is
helping inspiring training other people
to become property investors which is
why it's fantastic to have granting a on
the show been making around about 10,000
pound profit in properties they quit
their full-time jobs and they've done
that through the strategy of serviced
accommodation so I'm gonna be picking
their brains we're going to be drawing
upon lessons share with you guys so you
can do the exact same thing too so thank
you so much for coming out to the
offices all the way from Swansea no
problem when did you guys when did
utilize and how did you guys get started
in property so Wow um we met a couple
years ago and going into property was
really grants passion it wasn't really
my thing I've worked in more perforins
pretty much since I was a kid and when
me and grant met it was like we've gotta
get into property because that's that's
how we're going to get out of work
obviously that was what we wanted to do
so he dragged me along to a three-day
event that just explained all the
options or the strategies available yeah
because I didn't really know what I
wanted to do and because I had was
earning the least amount wages it made
sense I came out of work first right and
you learn on a small way okay so um
serviced accommodation just it matched
me because I could transfer a lot of my
skills my previous job so I was a retail
manager okay so how's that similar to
service - combination well guest
communication I guess relations you see
service accommodation it is I almost I
promise you investing as a business so
this correlation
really is a business you've got people
you know you're they're not really
tenants their customer yeah so
absolutely I guess that is a really
important skill and
of course we've got our investors /
clients that we manage their profit and
loss for them we do refurbs world
imagine different groups of people the
time yeah and being super organized
which was my thing anyway
clearly not grants but that's and grants
strength was how he formed into this was
he was really good at finding the deals
the communication between us and the
investors finding the investors to work
with us yeah and that's how we fell so
you're like the deal maker yeah yeah and
then yeah then you know what we're
really lucky because both of us have
strengths that complement each other
yeah so the one piece of advice that I
can give to anyone is it can get lonely
sometimes doing any job I mean I was I
did a field role and I was on my own all
the time so the best thing I can advise
is to get someone that can complement
your own skills and yeah utilize your
strengths absolutely but know when
you've got weaknesses and try and
leverage those weaknesses with people
that are good at them I couldn't go out
buying stuff for a house and setting it
up and making it look pretty
kay can absolutely do that when they
return the deals what was the what was
the passion in Greg what was the real
driving force I know like properties of
vehicle to achieve Lily yeah right
unless that sound like that's how I'm
gonna say it what was the what was the
driver what did you want to get K have a
job so I we were in relationships
beforehand we both got divorced I met K
or came at me we both met each other and
I decided to move to Swansea from as you
could probably tell I'm not Welsh I'm
from this side of the country near in
this or Gatwick way and when I when I
moved to Wales there was one thing that
I realized is that the property part is
a hell of a lot cheaper than down oh so
that's what initially sparked my thought
of oh I could do this and but what I
didn't realize was actually when I got
myself educated because of next thing
that I'd say is whether you read books
whether you watch your YouTube video
whether you go and pay for a course or
an event or seminar whatever that is get
yourself educated because when I got
educated I realize you can do property
anywhere in the country and if I'd have
known that information when I lived down
this side of the country the property
prices wouldn't have scared me right
sure
do you know how many I know exact times
it's the same story you just have a zero
on the end and actually in expensive
areas you can make even more money the
cheaper areas but the problem is the
area to the entry to Baron the barrier a
true story is is so much higher it
amused appears in London a lot of people
just take himself out the game straight
away because they're scared by the zeros
yes yeah and without hearing Wales and
you thinking wow this house is fly yeah
80 gram yeah 50 grand and some parties
and villagers yes you know 100 grand
like this listen this is kind of doable
so talk to talk me through your first
deal and how that happens Wow the first
deal so I'd read how hundreds of books
and and educated myself and helped try
and educate K as best as I possibly
could but K works so hard that she she
was she had so much time dedicated to a
current job that I just went out there
and started doing it so the key thing
for me was massive massive action all
the time so I was obsessed with
Rightmove Zoopla with gun generation and
you know I was quite funny I've got my
first deal off of gongs room Wow
so I kept messaging people on gumtree a
lot of people told me to go away to piss
off and I was just like oh shot down
shot down shot yeah just people on
gumtree with properties so anyone who
has and well we decided what our
strategy was gonna which was a service
so we were looking into serviced
accommodation so I was looking for a
place to rent that was a two to four
bedroom terraced house in swansea that
was within two miles of the city centre
yeah so once I found something that
suited back I'd send them a message and
to be fair I said tons of messages to
tons of people and then this one person
just parked up and asked a few questions
and that's when I saw my and started
explaining it to him
and it was it was really nice to get
that first deal over the line because
that's probably the hardest bit about
getting involved in property and and
also thinking that it's possible as well
because actually you might try a couple
times and then quit and think oh I'm not
going to do it but the trouble is if you
quit that's when you can't do it it
doesn't matter whether it takes you a
week to get your first property or
whether it takes you a year to get your
first property if you quit you're never
going to do it but if you get that first
one it's sort of like it it bursts the
month yeah this is the door when you
when you pop that balloon it just starts
flashing through and and it really is
you start getting deal after deal after
deal because your confidence goes from
oh I haven't got my debt first deal yet
I know what I'm doing and and actually
that mindset change even though your
skills probably are exactly the same as
they were before the mindset change
China takes you from one place to
another I love that I always say you
first deals always your hardest deal not
just the security but the management of
there if it's a service de combination
you everything you're negotiating the
deal for the first time but then you do
everything for the first time yeah so
you have a nightmare well it wasn't a
nightmare and but grant you know and
some of the old terraces you get like
that wood chip wallpaper yeah it was
like yeah we'll just paint over it
this is why I don't do have to take this
off and in doing so all the walls just
fell down and we had to you know this is
why else for you though yeah it is widel
yeah I've got houses in Wales and
honestly the walls just there's so much
down yeah in the houses they did the
walls sometimes just so we did that we
did
to dip it our wedding fund Oh at the
time and I think it was about three and
a half thousand wasn't it to be glad you
dipped your wedding fund oh absolutely
the thing is people say things to me
like I've got ten grand saved up for my
wedding and I'll say just invest it in
just invest in yourself man go spend it
on a program or a property or something
don't dance don't you know it really
freaks people out because most people's
minds it's like this is the most
important thing but if you get married
in your windows gone in the diamond
well that property made back that money
we'd reinvest it before the wedding so
talk me through the figures name okay so
this property you bought the number that
you rented and then you rented out
service accommodation right yeah how
much do you have to put in and how much
we make so the first the numbers on the
first property were we secured a
3-bedroom terraced house for $450 a
month I'm in Swansea within two miles of
the city center it's actually a five
minute walk from the Liberty Stadium and
so it's a really really good location
obviously we made a little bit of a
boo-boo in terms of the anticipating how
much it would cost to set up right so we
had to end up paying an extra three and
a half thousand pounds to refer the
property but the deal actually because
it was only four hundred and fifty
pounds a month it worked out that we
were getting a good deal over the three
years and I'm actually making the month
on that so per month that property
averages two thousand three hundred
pounds in bookings every month
why um in our first month we started
making money straight away if you make
me want to turn my Wales houses into so
I know would work for serviced
accommodation but I've got such lovely
downs in I just don't go to kick them
out do you know what I think it's a
balance really because like you you know
there are lots of people that want to
visit Wales and that's where service dog
accommodation provides a great service
but also you've got the balance of we
don't eight
anyhow because no one having where to
live yeah so this really is crazy cousin
in Swansea area and not just wander a
lot of Wales like Cardiff the houses are
so cheap to rent you can rent a nice wee
bit have like 450 500 yeah but then but
then they are popular tourist
destinations as well yeah so that's why
it lends itself quite well to serviced
accommodation because there's a lot of
development going on that like as an
example fast forward to today there's
lots of purpose-built student
accommodation going up which is heard
the HMO market in Swansea Mazzio but
they didn't quite finish the student
accommodation in time
right for the new semester so we secured
a 35,000 pound booking for students that
needed to stay in our properties for a
period of six weeks while they were
finishing the student accommodation so
while those purpose-built buildings are
hurting the HMO market this isn't to say
that Swansea is a bad place for emotion
you just have to change your tactics
orbit but with with serviced
accommodation with extra students not
only do we benefit from friends and
family visiting but we also benefit from
the hiccups that happen in these
developments because you know not only
do we cater for the contractors that are
working on them but we also cater for
mistakes and delays in the accommodation
for the students as well yeah so it has
a knock-on effect to everything how many
winners Wednesday's have you watched on
my channel do reckon I probably watch a
couple I'd like to be honest when I
watch youtube videos
I literally press play on whatever
series it is and it just goes through
everything yeah and so probably have a
cup of I know you guys are what like
consumed all of my online content and
books stuff like that yeah it's so the
biggest like what's been the biggest
thing that you've learned that this
helped you knew German specifically from
I would say your book was really good
buy low rent high yeah and and it's that
concept of with with because I read it
really early on in doing my property
stuff and it's probably actually when
read that it was just as we were
deciding what to do and actually the the
by low renin high strategy was was
really inspirational because actually it
takes and it's not it can come across
the reason why I didn't read it at first
because I read the title and I was that
all does that seem a little bit off to
me like should I be you know doing
people out of money both ends yes I
tried now you like to help people so
you're thinking this whole lot you see
my book title a couple years ago but I
read the book and actually it's just you
know looking at every angle for everyone
so buy at the lowest possible price that
works for everyone yes and and rent at
the highest possible price that works
for everyone and if that works for
everyone bit that was sort of missing
from the title for me that I didn't put
those things where they just want to
make the money I know I'm thinking about
all but what about the pool investor all
the purple or a tenant or whatever but
the bottom line is if you try and rent a
property out for more than it's worth
it just won't ready no and people only
pay what it's worth anyway so by low
rent Heinz is really just a case of buy
a property in an area where you can get
probably four but still do you man the
rents hard where you can make the
property so attractive because you've
got people like yes you can rent it
really high but investors like this
possibly get good return I guess I guess
the most I say inspirational thing that
I saw and this just come to mind was the
funnel for freedom challenge they yeah
that was really really good and you know
you could see the genuinity behind what
you were doing and yeah absolutely
people starting out in property I'm
gonna have the knowledge that you have
but I think the message is still the
same if you've got the knowledge yeah
you can start with nothing yeah for sure
and I think I did the exact same
strategies what you guys are doing which
is service in my first financial yeah
same story in showers you want to watch
right so just got anything and you've
basically all
mirror that done the same in Swansea and
now you work working on bigger we
started we started with 30,000 pounds
well I started with 30,000 pounds worth
for dead
Wow and I haven't paid it off because I
chose to keep it as a debt and manage it
on a monthly basis but we have banked
that money in the bank so if I wanted to
pay it off occurred yeah but we've got
the cash there so I thought I have the
cash yeah of course I thought was it K
then before before deciding I wanna get
into property you know doing some
training and then actually been in the
position where you can quit your job
like how long did that take
well we started in January last yeah and
I left work in October okay pretty fast
I'm gonna make sell bread because I know
you've not quit work as well yeah
Norwegian was even higher so you had
it's not easy to replace yeah so so kay
was nervous she still had a sixty
thousand pound wage for me coming in
yeah right so when I quit that was that
was a tough decision to make because we
had to we did have to make sure that the
money was coming in so Kay did a
fantastic job in driving the business
forward when she quit work because there
was no point her quitting work and not
moving it forward so I quit work and
when Kay quit we were on we had four
properties to that we had ourselves and
then the rest under management yeah so
Kay then grew it from 4 to 18 which is
when I quit an IT that's incredible I
left my job well I handed my notice in
July yeah and I left in September
remember fantastic what's life like now
then is folks on property investors busy
but exciting and you're investing all
that time back on yourself
yep in the morning you're just more
engaged and excited about what you're
going to do for the day because you know
it is you're doing it for you I'm
working harder yeah hard right like you
you you do it to have freedom and more
time yeah
and yet absolutely there's freedom more
time but I choose to work harder
but then that's why most people but you
know the succeeding property they think
they want to do it too long on a beach
forever no but actually nobody think
that yeah but they think that they're
gonna want to do that but I've never met
anyone unless they're maybe really old
and they've worked a really really long
hard life but I've never met anyone it's
certainly your life trying they want to
become financially free then just wants
to learn of each forever what happens is
then they can get grip why mission or
purpose and they want to they want to
they get addicted to growth growing
themselves they get addicted to whatever
they're doing so I mean what would you
say your biggest reason why is what's
the real real reason I think our biggest
reason well I have two one is definitely
joint but the biggest one is leaving a
legacy for our kids for children between
us and giving them the best start in
their life that they can have yeah and
then the second off me is just when we
decide to slow down on their so you stop
slow down it's actually just spend every
day with each other and enjoy each
other's time and do whatever it is that
we want to do in the moment without
having to take into consideration in
finances or you know responsibilities is
just you know let's just just go to
Italy next week let's just do it this
whatever that's my passion is amazing
you can you can do that now yeah what is
what phenomenal is the change in our
children's yes we've decided to go on
this path you know sixteen-year-old
daughter has got such an entre new
entrepreneurial spirit she's started up
her own business in our bloomin office
you know and one of our sons is is
basically Brighton down these dolls and
what he wants to achieve and and his
house that he wants to have when he's
older and really descriptive as to what
he wants right you know that is though
you've not had to give you kids money
but what happened is you've been a role
model to them and when they see you
stepping out York
and grow in and being excited you become
a role model and then I think kids will
then pick that up and I love you the
best gift I mean I've got two kids as
well a lot younger than your kids but I
think the best gift I can give my kids
is my best self yeah yeah you know
rather than and I'm not planning on
giving my kids any money it's that whole
thing you can teach someone to fish
isn't it yeah you know if you teach
someone to fish they can feed yourselves
for life but most teachers like school
teachers even if you go to business
school you learn enough someone who's
not doing it ya know
well thank you so so so you can send
your kids to the top business schools
and stuff but they're gonna learn from
it it's fake
yeah it's just theory and you can if you
try and teach your kids oh you know be
happy or I'll choose to our partner and
our Bishop this won't follow your dreams
but you're not following your dream
you're not taking many risks you're not
then they're not going to listen to what
you say they're just gonna copy what you
do yeah yeah I'm really it's great to
see what you guys are doing you become
the five people that you spend your most
time with dunno so ok spend a lot of
time with us so we're one of those we or
two of those five people that may spend
their time with ya an exact same thing
is happening with one of my best friends
that says diamonds come and live with us
so one of my best friends decided to
come and live with us Eva's always been
great with his hands you know
maintenance man extremely good at
refurbs and but he's never been
successful I came and live with us and
he started up his own company and he's
got three people working for him man
he's only been with us for less than a
year nine months that's a great sell and
I think as well the you can't help
people by being so if you want to help
the poor you can't help them what be
important you know you can only pull
people up yeah you know so oh and when
you in a position with abundance and
when you become successful it's so easy
to pull people up yeah so that's great
that you doing that give me the top
three best tips then in regards to what
you've done room service accommodations
specifically because I know people are
gonna be watching this thinking you know
that's great for you but but how like
wanted you one of the best if you can
both give me some tips maybe see a few
tips go ahead right I'll do the first
one you do one now I did a last
the number one biggest tip and this is
this is you know anything that you do is
to never ever stop taking action every
single day yeah well I I want to give
one specific to serviced accommodation
and that will probably be never ever
stop trying to find deals yeah if you're
always searching and always looking to
find deals thing well things will always
be there when you need it and actually
it's better to have more than you need
than not enough
that's brilliant you know what great
love that point so much because a lot of
people they get two or three deals and
everything I've stopped but you know
that's a nice last night everytime
hombre I'll go to the shop instead of
stocking up your couch what is lenio new
colors and then it's like probably boom
oh you know so not that cool k give us
some wisdom okay so for me particularly
it would be we didn't do this by
ourselves we were always surrounding
ourselves by people who were in the
service to commendation industry already
so that we could learn from people that
were doing it you know we started out
with nothing but we haven't got what
we've got from just ourselves it's it's
the education so we are part of a group
that we talk to about service
accommodation on a weekly basis we
attend certain meetings to do a property
and engage with people like-minded so
don't do it by yourself it will just
take you longer to get where you want to
go that's really just being around
people that do the same thing that you
want instantly fade yourself
it's environment isn't it yeah you know
there's this set of them if it's true
but if you put a baby shark in a fish
tank it will never grow more than eight
inches yeah because it can't and in the
same way that's such a brilliant tip it
education is important and one of the
reasons that we put on training programs
and Facebook groups and things is so
people can get the knowledge but just as
importantly I think it's the environment
so awesome number three number three
they're trying to think the third one
you know what yeah that I'd say the
highest value tasks in a serviced
accommodation business yeah okay might
not let me apply me for saying this but
it is absolutely revenue management the
highest value type revenue management so
managing your prices understanding where
where your customers are coming from and
who your customers are and how your
pricing reflects those task analysis I
don't do that so there's there's a
there's a number of ways of managing it
and if you I've only got one or what web
say one to four properties I'd say you
can do it all yourself and manually and
you know how do you find out the market
and what you get again in terms of the
market you have to be all over the
online travel agents so the key to is
booking calm and Airbnb we do a lot of
our research actually on booking.com
over air B&B because it's a lot easier
to see all of the competition as well
because you want to mark a compare
yourself to house so what are you
looking for so you're on booking.com
let's say you've got a little property
in Swansea in Church Road and you think
this is gonna work yeah you're gonna go
on booking.com you're gonna see what
else is around
yes around that proximity maybe within
how far quarter of a mile off a lot you
can do it in quite a decent proximity a
couple miles maybe and you're gonna do
what are you specifically before you
looking for the how much are they
charged in and what are people paying
what else is looking for you're looking
for where you're looking for exactly
that so you're looking for where you
could realistically charge to get
bookings and what quality the
accommodation needs to be at yeah and
and once you've got that picture in your
head all it is is looking at what you
could possibly charge and they looking
for the how full the hotels are you're
not necessarily on booking.com actually
if you do a search for dates it'll
actually tell you as long as you're on a
desktop then it tells you on a mobile
now but on a desktop it tells you what
percentage the areas filled up by and
good a good test is anything
a 70% fall right and so if you look at
next week as an example and it's 70%
full that's fantastic yeah that's a
really good really good place to be so
so how do you compare it might be that
there's there's hotels that are filled
up 70% but there are things like you
know holiday in help zone and then you
think you might have two little house
what what does a customer think when
they're looking at these different
options and then they see your property
do you know that they're booking on -
just a little house how do they feel
about that I think you've got a look at
what people are paying per person so and
one of the people that we worked with
worked alongside and learnt with
previously did per person per night as a
company and it is a fantastic concept
because it not only allows you to market
yourself right but also gives you a good
gauge as to how you price yourself as
well so we're serviced accommodation
comes in into its own is with three and
five people because two people you can
get a hotel room three people and you're
probably going to have to get two hotel
rooms yeah do you see what I mean yeah
so per person two hotel rooms is going
to be a lot more expensive than getting
a small house yes and that's what you
specializing right you just so you don't
get little one bed studios and with them
now you're getting a house and then the
market is people that might be in a room
and they're thinking a fortune yes to
put four rooms at the Halloween we don't
want to share a double bed we'll get
really in it
we'll get how sorry there's got three
rooms Ange is a little sick kitchen
perfect we don't do anything below two
bedrooms how is okay how high in do you
go I'd go higher if I could but my
budget mistakes me how I what does it
look like when you're walking has he
compared to say holiday oh do you know
what this is the finishing touches y
know is the right amazing yeah things
you've got to go
which is awesome but you've got to go I
think land when you do service
accommodations especially if you want to
beginning decent people and it doesn't I
don't think it costs that much to make
it look really nice it doesn't actually
especially if you shop like a shop where
do you shop I'm a good shopper I get the
deals where do you go that oh it's a
great place in songs you know yeah home
sense they've amazing walls he came
around with me and I was actually set up
a house and he was driving the car who
lived in the news like never ever again
what'd I ever do shopping yeah it's a
specifically as I said this is a really
bad use of my time I'd rather have paid
someone 10 pound an hour to go around
and do it with her she just wanted
something heavy lifting yes yes because
I like my time's worth more than that
yeah absolutely and that's and that's a
really important point actually
I mean if where do you decide whether
you're out for something or not um I
think we decide that we're neither it
becomes it's just just taking that too
much of our time it is something that we
can outsource or potentially it's gonna
be a bowl that's gonna belong to
somebody
long term and we'll we'll actually
recruit someone to do that payment on
Japanese stuff yet
yes I'll be obviously we've got we've
got a cleaners which you know yeah we
might like paying they're like freelance
outs or yeah but we've got one full-time
employee who started off as a property
manager but we know as sheep as it
develops her strength is in guest
relationship management so she's
probably going to move into that role as
we grow because it will become a
full-time role that's what you see what
I think is I always just think if I'm
anything that I'm doing I just think
could I pay someone to do this and how
much would they charge is that less than
my hourly rate
absolutely correct
I know am i worth it yeah if you're if
you're let's say you're worth 50 pounds
an hour I mean your property business
that's what you know your hourly rate
but you've gotta know you're early right
why would you ever do anything ever
including washing the car cut in the
garden why would you to do it unless you
just happen to love it and it recharge
you exactly should not be doing it so
yeah so there's two rules to how
identify whether I outsource something
do I really enjoy doing it you never
will enjoy it or or is it worth my time
people live sometimes I have some of my
students that I like doing this and I'm
like you know yeah all I enjoy washing
the car I mean I enjoy cutting the
garden yeah having to do it having to
cut the lawn in the summer every week or
so and it becomes it's a burden if you
enjoy do everything because everyone's
warning the neighbors you know okay so
what's next step for you guys you make
how much you're making a month of the
minute in profit so profit we are
looking at if we take everything that we
have so we do have we do have a
buy-to-let property we have got
everything problem with everything
property we're making over ten thousand
pounds profit per month is bed man whose
bed that's amazing
and that's a big deal because that's for
a lot of people that's ultimate
financial freedom which means that not
only do you not have to work to pay the
bills you don't have to work to have a
really good life which is fantastic
achievement
so what's makes me guys well I will
explain what we're doing with the
serviced accommodation business and
we're gonna be growing our business 250
plus properties this time next year
trigger scary right absolutely yeah and
obviously that will involve recruiting
more people having in-house staff that
will be available 24/7 and then we'll
also be looking at other avenues of how
we're gonna what are you gonna use
managers what else
sorry using the profits hopefully
building your own yeah so so absolutely
so we're going to be using the addition
profits to build up her own portfolio in
assets but also I'm going to be working
with investors to start tidying up some
of the run-down guest houses that are on
Britain's seafront and and that is
something that I'm really passionate
about there's houses down the sea for it
that have run down what do you do them
so the guest houses would take I mean
buy them up so with investors buy that
but alike as an example you doing that
to people
yes in that wait you're thinking big
scaling yes I'll have to work really
hard save money and buy one you're gonna
you're gonna raise the finance
absolutely buy a house or houses down
the sea silently doing yeah do more
beautifully and then what refinance them
yes we find them better then pull it
give them back to the investor and go
from there and they've read them out how
sorry and then run them out now don't be
a guest house so what we're gonna do is
we're going to do it almost like a
serviced accommodation concept but in a
hotel format so each rooms going to have
its own kitchenette and ensuite and then
each room is going to have its own code
to get into so you don't have you don't
have a reception and you don't have a
restaurant because everyone has their
own cooking facilities and we have is
cleaners cleaning the common areas in
the rooms fantastic so there's no staff
required what's your exit strategy
doesn't work the exit strategy you
hopefully is deaf but the thing with
guest houses right guest houses have
been around for hundreds and hundreds of
years so the the likelihood of us
needing to sell them isn't very likely
but the if we needed to would probably
look at selling them so I would be the
exit strategy but probably a very very
on my leg yes because I would say you
know in everything whenever you go into
business you always look at best guys
worst case of like the case yes
so I guess that'd be absolutely I guess
that's our strategy with anything that
we buy is if we needed to
if you know [ __ ] hit the fan and we can
sell the property funny because I yeah
you started out by just making some
calls to landlords and get tell them
that you know yeah going to go into a
property of man watching youtube videos
making those few calls and now I'm
thinking right now
may contain vitamin want to get we
employ more people
50 it's now real big but it all starts
from those first steps anyone watching
this what would be the thing right now
you would tell them go and do this go
and do whatever it is you said you were
gonna do and do it now so everyone's got
an idea about what actions they need to
take to get into the next step and then
so many people just keep putting it off
yeah if it's really you passion to go
and achieve something then you would
make time and you would do it just just
face those fears just to build on that I
think the one key thing that that helped
me was to stop [ __ ] all over
yourself and turn your shoulds into mus
because if you keep saying everyday I
should do this I should do that I should
go and make this call I should send this
email you don't gonna go and do it
you've got to do it I must do this I
must do that and that determination make
you take the action yeah great
so stop walking things often
procrastinate yeah just go and do it
love that the Nike just do it absolutely
hey guys it's been great it's been great
having you in the office thanks I'm
sharing the story cheering you on all
the way if you guys if you've been
watching this video and you've been
shooting all over yourself for the last
few months or years now it's time to do
something a little bit different so take
action pick up the phone call some
landlords get out there until networking
event come on down to one of our
training events just do something take
action and I look forward to having some
people on the show real soon
[Music]